>> ♪ ♪
TIME FOR OUR SEEN AND UNSEEN
SEGMENT.
WE EXPOSE WHAT IS BEHIND THE BIG
CULTURE STORIES OF THE DAY.
LAST NIGHT WE BLEW THE LID OFF
THIS TIME'S UP INITIATIVE.
HOLLYWOOD ELITE BANNED TOGETHER
POLITICAL MOVEMENT AGAINST
REPUBLICANS INCLUDING DONALD
MEMBER OF TIME'S UP, MERYL
STREEP, MAY PROVE MY POINT.
I AM JOINED BY MANAGING EDITOR
AND FOX CONTRIBUTOR.
RAYMOND.
>> SHE DID AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS IS CALLED
SELF-PRESERVATION.
HE HAS A LOT TO ANSWER FOR.
ROSEANNE ACTESS ABUSED BY HARVEY
WEINSTEIN CHARGED MERYL STREEP
THE IRON LADY THE GIVER.
HE HELPED SHAPE THOSE FILMS.
THEY WERE VERY CLOSE.
THEY SAY MERYL STREEP KNEW OF
THIS ABUSE AND WAS SILENT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" TODAY
PRESSED MERYL STREEP ON THIS.
SHE GOT VERY TESTY.
>> Laura: VERY DEFENSIVE.
>> Laura: HE CALLED HIM GOD.CTIO
>> Laura: HE CALLED HIM GOD.
IN THE LAST GOLDEN GLOBES SHE
LAST GOLDEN GLOBES.
>> WHAT SHE SAID TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" TODAY:
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THE
SILENCE OF MELANIA.
SHE HAS SO MUCH VALUABLE TO SAY
AND SO DOES IVANKA.
>> Laura: MELANIA AND IVANKA
HAVE
HAVE SP
HAVE SPOK
HAVE SPOKEN
HAVE SPOKE
HAVE SPOKEN.
HIM.
A LOT OF DEFLECTION.
HOLLYWOOD TRYING TO ABSOLVE
THEMSELVES.
AND PAUL ONE OF MY FAVORITE
ACTORS.
HE SAID TODAY.
TMZ.
>> HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HIS
DAUGHTER.
MIRA.
MERYL STREEP WHEN WERE YOU WHEN
SHE HAD HER CAREER TANKED.
SHE WAS AN ACADEMY AWARD WINNER
AND HER CAREER TANKED.
>> IF I MEET HIM ON THE STREET,
HE OUGHT TO HOPE HE GOES TO
JAIL.
SOMEHOW.
MAGICALLY.
>> Laura: GOOD FELLOWS ALL OVER
AGAIN.
>> THAT WAS JUST THE OPENING.
CAREER.
MIRA.
THEY COME OUT WITH TIMES UP.
GET OUT.
WHAT THEY KNEW.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THEIR OWN
CAREER'S ROCKED AND WANTED
HARVEY'S HELP.
>> AND SCAPEGOAT ON MELANIA AND
IVANKA.
>> Laura: AND ANDERSON COOPER
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE POT BEING
SMOKED.
>> RANDI KAYE WENT TO THIS POT
DEN IN DENVER.
THIS WAS CNN'S NEW YEAR'S EVE
COVERAGE.
ANDERSON COOPER WAS SHOCKED!
>> Laura: THEY WERE ALL DRUNK!
WHAT WAS HE SHOCKED BY?
WANT TO PAINT IN DAY-GLO COLORS.
IT SURPRISED ME AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> SURPRISED HIM?
>> Laura: CAN'T WE LOSE THE
"LIKE."
>> HOW THIS REFLECTS AMERICA I
DON'T KNOW.
BILL WEIR IS IN KEY WEST GETTING
GROPED BY GUYS.
WATCH THIS.
>> HERE IS THE DRAG QUEEN KNOWN
AS SUSHI.
>> [CHEERING].
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> [LAUGHING]
SHOCKED BY THE POT DEN.